[Music]
momiji no tempura to you Noah dento
Takeda Oh Cassie desert sense ambi
economy Cassie Misaka nobody mascara
Domo Oh Cassie Nina tell Ronnie no naka
de namaha secretion scotomas massa
watashi wa kono mama no temprano
boodikka que mató a mighty master
version engine our innocence Momiji doe
temprid do you know a better arrows
Momiji until now
serega you must aim at Ahava vent a
medicine kiraku tea do you know Miyako
Nara Qaeda the children east of Austin
emo yo mo kawaranai de la soie kono
sukadeva konasana Papa 300 GaN Jiu Shi
okay mr. Whitley mistake deported step
the a guru talking SEO we take the
promotes good so that they are getting
to you know move a brand on the scale at
all
[Music]
I know Momiji no temporada tokidoki nama
databases Tito circles end as a
pessimist movie girl temprano Vegeta
Noah was a to hide the mascara imagine
not the muscle desert green show eating
bison and SEO bachata Katara kini
catotti Oh toto no 8a again you know ha
sorry Dom APIs or a roto keynote
terminology which edema
hachijuni monogamous Kodama movies no
temperature limit tonicity Inca cut our
usual system linear temporal term
artificial on I dead Ferrari Rock atomic
scientist answer ok atomic a ferrari t
OE CT terminal tokoha
so go ahead
[Music]
me that day a lot do one those are cool
dr. Stan when - he had cuts on silly
dumb sedin finca tatin me on appeal ah
yeah me dr. John Cena meet the husband
and wife team selling a delectable treat
on the streets of Bangkok you tool into
victory Linda Lake Mohave the couple met
six years ago when Bertie was
frequenting Lex stall
they eventually were married and she
joined his business today
they sell a variety of deep fried
insects near khao sarn road a popular
tourist area while their menu may vary
their process is the same so let's start
at the beginning which is actually the
end of the day look come on be sold in
in this home look at home look at a clue
I want a little high millennial traveler
a better life is cinema Lane we see what
to do but EMI the beurre monté and
to say from what I know I love my life
I said it man look at all in another one
without money among couldn't handle like
a dead hand behind her and if you think
that all bugs tastes the same think
again Steve my lucky new music I think
of me from time
and in killing dr. Nikki llama tell you
know when money money entire Saturday
initial or cocoa when Konya young lord
Joaquin Kidman manual when pathology
t-bar Liliana to me that there who are
teeny million diving down younger so a
movement for me my new time Thomas Hart
helping put out a fire dongsung PC me
could have pain eating bugs used to be
associated with poverty in Thailand but
that's not the case anymore and it's not
just tourists who enjoy this novel treat
get in the van come heal in Malaya while
learning to magic English car bottom
woman so masterful higher for higher let
the kid grew up Saturday and Malayan
Joel English Ben yeah but what Lacan
vitória appreciate most is the support
they provide for each other each and
every day
well I think I found what I work as a
fighter
what are you maybe you and you can make
up company I'm gonna come Columbus sorry
[Music]
when you think of Japanese cuisine a few
foods come to mind sushi did you know
that salmon sushi is actually Norwegian
yeah we did a story on that one maybe
you think of mochi we did that one too
and tempura but guess what tempura is
actually a Portuguese dish oh boy here
we go
the Japanese tempura you know is done
two ways either with seafood or with
vegetables right and the batter is light
made with cold water wheat flour and egg
pretty standard this tempura can be
found dating back to the end of the 16th
century in Japan but as we know Japan is
much older than that so why did it
suddenly show up
the answer is Portugal around 1543 a
Chinese ship with three Portuguese
sailors got off course and landed in
Japan on Tanegashima Island
fast-forward a bit and the Portuguese
because of this happy accident are now
trading goods and arms with the Japanese
then in 1639 the Portuguese were kicked
out of the country a few things however
remained including a dish of battered
and fried beans called machines they
ortho useful versions sub-rule cooked
here pushing years old that's Manuela
Brenda chef I Papa sorta one of the best
spots in Lisbon to get as she's they
were thought machine is the water cycle
sustained special very good Aziza was
really informative
really OSR Gavin huevos I gotta bail
no Seco the society who because racy not
OSHA for me is now of course over the
past 400 years Japan has put its own
spin on the dish but you know it's a fun
fact next time somebody in your group
orders tempura
the creation of the potato chip is a
rather snarky surprising an
idiosyncratic story when french fries
made their way to America they soon
became a restaurant mainstay many
restaurants serve fries as their
signature dish
believe it or not they were once
considered very hoity-toity in 1853
George Crum was a chef at the moon's
lake house in Saratoga Springs New York
their signature dish was none other than
moons fried potatoes or as the
aristocrats would say potatoes served in
the French manner one day just like any
other a customer some believed to have
been Cornelius Vanderbilt himself
ordered fries upon being served
Cornelius scoffed and sent them back he
deemed the fries soggy and not crispy
enough this insanity intended a few more
times until Crum lost it I mean he
really lost it he fired back cutting the
potatoes paper-thin and frying them up
you see back in 1853 eating with your
hands was a major faux pas making crumbs
revenge even more diabolical by cutting
the potatoes paper-thin there would be
no way that Cornelius could use his fork
forcing him to use his hands crumbs plan
backfired
kind of as the patrons dug in with both
hands and loved them Saratoga chips were
born they became a Saratoga dining
staple soon thereafter they took the
world by storm Crum himself even opened
his own restaurant
with baskets of chips displayed on each
and every table
[Music]
salty sweet chewy crunchy it's a
delicious combination born from one of
black America's most consequential
cultural movements it was the 1930s the
place was New York City
it was the epicenter of black Americans
movement into mainstream culture the
Harlem Renaissance artists writers and
thinkers would gather at venues and
Harlem into the wee hours of the morning
listening to touring big bands and jazz
artists as the club stayed open later
and later
so did local restaurants to take in the
hungry concert goers one such restaurant
owner was Josie T Wells founder of Wells
supper club Wells became known for its
southern inspired menu but Wells needed
a hit to stay on top of the 2 a.m.
restaurant business what could he do
seeing an opportunity Wells realized
that the fried chicken leftovers from
dinner could be served with a freshly
prepared waffles for breakfast creating
a sweet and savory concoction unlike
anything else the dish was a hit
eventually word got out and chicken and
waffles became a soul food staple from
Atlanta to Los Angeles and though Wells
closed in 1982 the dish lives on so when
you think of the Harlem Renaissance take
Duke Ellington jazz planks and huge
poetry and Joseph T Wells chicken and
waffles
[Music]